in this capsule we will start
the part of the course on agents
smart then among the goals
for this part so suddenly we go in
To define too much the notion of an agent
intelligent we will talk among others about the
concept of rational agents we will cover
the analysis p as major performances in
paramount pictures and thank you
will then distinguish different types
of environment and finally your
distinguish different types of agents
smart then in intelligence
artificial one can distinguish two
holly branches two goals are
come in intelligence research
artificial
the first is to understand what
question him years and specifically
human intelligence
so people who among other things
focus on more aspects
neuroscientist of intelligence are going
develop mathematical models of the
brain function then
development of mathematical models
among others neurons and their
functioning in cognitive science or
in psychology we will rather
focus on understanding the
human reasoning is among others this
we want to do is
develop models of reasoning
human to predict the performance
of a human in a given task of which
which among others
the architected actors that allows between
others to assess what is the risk
run by a person who speaks to
phone while doing the driving of
cars so in this case behind the
current architecture the ability to
mobility model forgiveness
the cursed tasking so a situation where
someone does several tasks at the same
time and therefore developing good
models of human reasoning one can
maybe hope to able to evaluate
what are the risks behind this genre
situation the 1 1 human being does a
some reasoning but we what is going
really interested us in the race
and create intelligent agents so
to replace us eventually he
make decisions possibly to
our place or to help us take
decisions and therefore want to develop
finally software that has some
fundamental capabilities associated with
intelligence as the perception the
knowledge representation
learning reasoning
then the ability to take
rational decisions
we give you here some examples
intelligent agents so we have to
example decision support system
which is right here we also have a
robotic platform that can be
move on a given piece of land another
robotic platform in what if in
the space exploration framework
we also have super mario so a
artificial intelligence in a game
video all these are examples
of intelligent agents and noticed between
other than an intelligence agent has not
need to be necessarily a robot
a robotic platform that can be
as much a software swimmer as in a
software environment that a swimmer
physical that interacts with with the
real world finally so before
talk about money to people why is
what we would like to develop agents
people why would we want
give a software a capacity
artificial intelligence
in fact this question is a pond
the finals why are we
wish to make the decision
automatic finally gave software
the ability to make decisions
automatically versus program and we
what is the actions that our
software could take so what we
means by programming of actions
it will be among others
screaming script or script
could describe all the possible
context in which our agent for himself
find and then at each context
enumerated ourselves by hand what is it
the actions that should be taken
by our software
we could make an approach maybe
a little more sophisticated we would have
machines was finished we would be in
able to describe maybe so
less exhaustive or a little more compact
what kind of context in which
could be our agent but in
does this approach is going to be
require a lot of work then
often it will be impossible to describe
all the context in which our
smart money could be
find on board to make decisions
and that's why we're going
particularly interested in actually
to the needy who can take
decisions automatically so we
wants the actions performed this not
not scripted or programmed at the
sale
we want money to decide for itself
that is to say that from a certain
calculation that is able to make a
reasoning something that one
we as a human being we could
associate with an ability to reason
so really here the bear who is at
heart of intelligent agents it's from
give their computers
the ability to make decisions and
have no program and expressive
threats what are his decisions to
take